so after watching Loki I have this idea
that Avengers King Dynasty is going to
have two main plot threats the first is
that it's going to show all these
different King variants wiping out
various superheroes in their respective
universes and that the second plot
thread is going to be the multiversal
Avengers however that team comes
together and whoever it consists of
traveling the Multiverse and then
rescuing what superheroes they can
realizing that like the king variants
are all over the place right that they
are killing off various Heroes they'll
be a little late to the game so that'll
explain why we don't have hundreds of
Iron Man variants and hundreds of
Captain America variant Because by the
time the superheroes realized what was
going on and by the time the time
variance Authority was able to muster a
superhero team assuming they're the ones
that bring it together so many
superheroes had already been killed so
then you go into Avengers Secret Wars
this has two main plot threats the first
one is that it gives us the main
conflict between the Kang variants and
and the surviving superheroes across the
Multiverse and then they're taken by
surprise with the incursions now the
whole idea of them taking by surprise
with the incursions is a very important
plot thread here and that is something
that I do want to talk about so for
those of you guys who are familiar with
the incursions in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you already know that it's the
result of just excessive travel between
realities we learned that in Doctor
Strange 2 when that reality's version of
Reed Richards John krinski was talking
to the main Marvel Cinematic Universe
version of doctor strange and saying our
reality's counterpart who was part of
our Illuminati team was dreamwalking and
he accidentally caused an incursion so
after Thanos Was Defeated we had to
destroy him right he had to go away and
of course they tried to kill the main
Marvel Universe Doctor Strange because
he's always a threat the other way that
we know that is because Janet van Dy in
her conversation with that variant of
King from the quantum realm in Quantum
Mania literally he told her that that
during the first multiversal war there
were endless incursions because all
these kangs were traveling between
Dimensions between universes and they
were all fighting each other here's the
kicker to all of this pretty much
anybody who knows about the incursions
is basically dead there's not really
even any indication as far as I'm aware
that the TVA knows about incursions they
haven't really referenced it as far as I
recall I could be wrong so I'm not going
to take that as an absolute truth but as
far as I'm aware they haven't referenced
the idea of incursions and universe's
ending due to to excessive travel
between realities and so everybody who
was part of the Illuminati and Doctor
Strange 2 they were destroyed by Scarlet
Witch so they can't tell anybody Janet
vany sure she knows but she was told by
a variant of Kang who's already been
destroyed presumably that this took
place during the first multiversal war
but she's not aware of all the other
king variants that exist out there
because of the events of Loki so there's
no reason for her to bring it up there's
no reason for her to tell anybody about
it so in effect the incursions are
basically happening in secret no one
knows that they're taking place except
for maybe the Kings and so that's why I
think that during the events of King
Dynasty the superheroes will learn about
the incursions and so I think what's
going to happen is during Avengers
Secret Wars they're going to kind of
have to make a choice they're going to
say like which one of these is the more
significant threat the incursions which
are resulting in universes crashing into
each other and wiping everything out or
these variants of Kang and I think
they're going to decide the Kang variant
are the greater threat here the reason
being because they're going to follow
the line of logic that Dr Doom had
during the events of the incursions in
Marvel Comics so for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with how the
incursions unfolded in the comic books
one it's way more interesting than what
you see in the comics and two it's all
because of Dr Doom now I'm not saying
that Dr Doom is going to be a focal
point in secret Wars or he's going to
play anywhere near as big of a role I
don't know it'd be cool if he did but in
the comic books the incursion happened
because there was a group of beings out
there called the beyonders and the
beyonders had this experiment they
wanted to conduct where they basically
engineered and deposited in every single
Universe a guy named molecule man Owen
Reese this guy has the ability to alter
matter on the molecular structure really
the atomic structure throughout the
entirety of a universe what that meant
is that when he dies the whole universe
would die with him and what the
beyonders wanted to do was kill all the
molecule man in every Universe across
the Multiverse at the same time just to
see what would happen because it would
destroy the Multiverse Dr Doom and
molecule man from the main Marvel
Universe realized what was going on so
they travel to an alternate reality that
alternate reality version of molecule
man was killed the whole universe was
destroyed and what it did is it pushed
the universes next to it into the
universes next to them so on and so
forth that's how the incursion started
the kicker about all this is that at the
end of John than Hickman's Avengers a
new Avengers run when you have the
molecule man Dr Doom and Doctor Strange
as as far as they're concerned the last
three surviving beings throughout the
entirety of the Multiverse prior to
their attack on the beyonders Dr Doom
asked Doctor Strange tell me do you
think it would be worth it if we could
save and Salvage at least something and
that's what the superheroes are going to
do right they're going to say look yes
there's these incursions These
incursions are crashing into whole
universes we don't even know how to stop
that yet but we do know how to stop
these Kings so we'll focus on them then
we'll worry about the incursions later
the problem is that the longer the fight
goes on the more universes are destroyed
and that whether it's because by the
time Avengers Secret Wars ends there's
only one Universe left and that's the
one that they're all fighting in or if
it's because there's only a handful of
universes left and by whatever Manner
and whatever means everything is going
to come to an end what's going to end up
happening here is we're going to come to
this realization the incursions cannot
be stopped there's no conceivable way of
stopping these universes from crashing
into each other it's just way too big
it's way too huge right that's how it
worked in the comics Iron Man knew that
as soon as he learned about the
incursions he knew about it before
anybody else did he just let everybody
believe there was a chance to win right
just kind of letting them do their thing
but knowing there was no possible chance
to win it was amazing Captain America
beat the hell out of him when he found
out it was
awesome but the fact remains here right
that by whatever Manner and whatever
means we're basically going to see the
full-on collapse of the Multiverse and
that it's all going to coales into a
singular timeline that's going to be
called new universe now I say new
universe not for any particular grandos
reason it's not like it was referenced
in Loki or anything like that it's
because in Marvel Comics they had a line
of stories called new universe it was
cool it was like what would happen if
people with powers existed in the real
world not the Ultimate Universe there
was no Spider-Man there was no Captain
America none of that stuff it's just
regular people you got like the white
event and stuff like that it was pretty
dope but it would make sense they would
simply just call it new universe and
that's it but it's a singular timeline
going forward but with all that being
said guys I want to know what you all
think and if you're curious about the
incursions in Marvel Comics click this
link to the playlist because it'll take
you to Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers run and you'll find a lot
of similarities between what's been
happening with Loki what happened in
Doctor Strange 2 everything in the
Multiverse Saga all that kind of stuff
the incursions the whole nine yards it's
all covered there but let me know what
you guys think down in the comment
section and I will catch you all later
peace